the stage was set for a prince who had
to get the tone just right in front of
54 nations selling himself as a man they
can't believe in to target the wrongs of
the past i want to acknowledge that the
roots
of our contemporary association
run deep into the most painful period of
our history
i cannot describe the depths
of my personal sorrow at the suffering
of so many
as i continue to deepen my own
understanding of slavery's enduring
impact
but also looking to the future and the
possibility of other realms cutting ties
with the royal family
i want to say clearly as i have said
before
that each member's constitutional
arrangement
as republic or monarchy
is purely a matter for each member
country to decide
the benefit of long life
brings me the experience that
arrangements such as these
can change calmly and without ranca it
was striking he felt he had to say
something recent world tours have seen
protests about the colonial past and
more calls to lose the monarchy it was
also his first chogham since it was
confirmed he will automatically follow
the queen as their next head so
interesting that her private secretary
edward young on the left of boris
johnson was part of the team
the prince is constantly trying to do
and say the right things always using
that word friendship and also
acknowledging it's now no longer enough
to talk in subtle terms about the
difficulties from the past people do
expect more but what is going to be
fascinating is to see how world leaders
adapt to his new kind of approach in the
years to
come the meeting in this room had
dominated the build-up the cameras
struggling to get in if the rwanda
immigration policy came up
thank you very much we don't know as the
cameras were quickly moved on leaving
two men who both know their leadership
credentials are being scrutinized it
takes a very courageous person to say
solely we commend him but perhaps more
should be done in terms of reparation
and compensation coming to africa where
slavery started you know people of
africa were victims to slavery and
saying that here was the most befitting
comment and i absolutely commend him and
praise him for that
you can tell he is a man still eager to
please but knows that relationships will
constantly change and sometimes you just
can't win everyone over rhiannon mills
sky news in kigali